laughs
and we are live good evening and welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel and tonight I am
I have young Mike with me who is a
newbie to the Sidetrack family but um
very welcome uh new friend to the
channel uh say hello Mike hello there
thank you very much for invited me I'm
not sure if I'm the youngest um co-host
you've ever had but uh I'll take that as
a compliment um lovely to be here
um I've only recently sort of discovered
your channel through my uh colleague
podcast colleague Martin Fowler and um
I'm a huge Stargate fan so um as he has
done as well recently I often just come
to your channel for
um Stargate news you know fingers
crossed that we're going to get
something in the not too distant future
um and so yeah I mean um I'm hopeful and
pessimistic so I don't know we have to
see how it goes won't we so uh yeah well
I will tell you something about that
after
um I do that little intro okay
so it is just short two seconds
um it's all right it's good
um I haven't I can't really tell you
much details with this but I am here in
Rumblings
um
basically we've got the mark Fergus
penguin and Parker looks like that deal
is sort of being negotiated at the
moment and they're going to develop new
Stargate right but I've always said they
needed another production company or
someone else that to actually make the
show a bit like the expanse right
penguin in a Parker developed and they
were all executive producers and
um amkron actually made the show they
were the production company okay
um it looks like
um there might actually be a deal
um be negotiated for that production
company but at the moment it's all rooms
so the sources that I speak evidence is
what you're saying is is yeah I'm
waiting for a bit of evidence to back it
up right but one of the rumors I'm
hearing I'll go as far as saying they
make sense okay
um I I have seen the expanse um I
thought the expanse itself as an entire
series was very very well made I think
it's one of the best uh contemporary
sci-fi shows I've seen
um I think if I'm right they did
um because it went at one point to
Amazon I know that it's been all over
the place it got renewed
um and it and he finished is it last
year it wasn't that long ago it finished
yeah early early 22. and
um
it's just a shame because
um I I wish I think there's like eight
books in the original novelistics
Three Seasons
um that could be made and there's been a
load of additional books and little
short stories um that span of 30 years
because between six and seven there's
actually a 30-year Gap oh right really
there are short stories and stuff that
fill that fill that Gap there's there
are lots of rumors that
um the expanse still could return
um at the the current my understanding
currently is Amazon have
um distribution rights on anything new
so they have um rights to the show until
uh early next year right amkron actually
owned the IP I am Amazon dunks they just
owned the distribution right oh that's
interesting okay that's an interesting
the current deal means that I'm can't
make anything for anybody else until
that deal runs out right the HBO Max are
very interested but skinned and Apple TV
is the is the most recent um
I mean HBO I've seen I just started
watching The Last of Us
um the fitting the first two episodes of
that and I think so far that's really
good it's fantastic and really good
apple I've seen foundation and For All
Mankind uh both series I've thoroughly
enjoyed as well
um so it's interesting how potentially
um one of these uh companies could get
involved in making it in the future or
something uh I hope so you know it'd be
great to be if it came back I mean
grappling desperate to get a big sci-fi
franchise apparently they did try to buy
well they did try to buy MGM okay before
they tried by MGM they tried to get MGM
to produce Stargate for them apparently
right and they've tried to get a stark
Trek
um show you know like Amazon did with
Picard they try to negotiate the deal oh
okay well before Paramount Plus
um obviously held it yeah okay yeah but
they've been desperately scrapping
around to try to get themselves a Sci-Fi
franchise so we'll see how that
developed I mean I think Foundation is
is certainly a very strong Contender
um it's only from what I've seen of it
it's only one season I think they're in
production in season two
um and I I did like the cast I remember
there was an episode with Alexander
siddick made an appearance of CD paper
Shear in DS9 it was nice to see him in
one episode
um and I I just thought it was it was
just a very well made
um sci-fi series and I I think that it's
not well known I mean I'm quite a Sci-Fi
geek so I do tend to find out about
these things but I don't know whether in
your circles whether it's well known
yourself or your colleagues as well I
mean otherwise only because I've read
the books but um a colleague I do if
Well story bear obviously regular
Sidetrack is no stormy bear he was a big
nut on it and he actually just happened
to ask me the ones have you heard
anything about a foundation series and I
that's how I found out because I thought
I don't know me so I sort of asked and
somebody went yeah so it's going to be
on Apple next year I was like oh okay no
it was there it goes and it was a
obviously had a lot of money pumped into
it because it looked like it was a
pretty well polished production
um and so relatively out of the
streaming services Apple are the only
cash Rich streaming service right now oh
that's interesting so why are they why
are they so strong compared to other a
stream of services at the moment Amazon
new or um Amazon have lost
um a significant a lot of money due to
lots of projects it was just like the
Drone project and things like this it
was just stupid
um but also I mean I think they over
invested during covid and then for some
reason they didn't seem to realize that
it would that their growth would slow
okay but um so they've lost significant
money Disney plus loses about 500
million dollars a quarter apparently
I am just trying to put con it was all
planned but it's all propped up by the
rest of the Disney Corporation well it's
such a big Corporation it's such a huge
entity that it can absorb those hits at
least um but I would assume that it's
not indefinite eventually they're gonna
have to think about how we're going with
this thing they were supposed to be
starting to make money this quarter
um but it hasn't gone to plan because
obviously now we've had to slow down
okay
um but they're they're still losing
money hand over fist
Paramount owe about 16 billion and don't
really know how to pay it and HBO
Discovery owe nearly 50 billion
so okay so uh
depths as well so there must be some uh
people Executives who are probably
having some sleep this night so I would
have thought with all that kind of like
uh yeah the background you know well
with the Slowdown as well of the
streaming was that this is why I think a
lot of projects that we thought again
like I said we thought were nailed on
six months ago or a year ago yeah and
now not have like the Battlestar
Galactica well we're going to be talking
about reboots so yeah we are going to
talk about that yeah so
um there was supposed to be another
Battlestar Galactica review
um there's been there's been all sorts
of projects that I've talked about on
this channel that are just starting
yeah it seems to be being slowed down
and money seems to be the main issue
well from my perspective I think we all
know this is quite obvious that we're
obviously during the covid pandemic
um people were at home more and they
wanted entertainment and this is why
everything kind of took off and which
was something which is going to be
likely to happen eventually you know
although we're not in quite a normality
but it is feeling a bit more uh before
the pandemic came down and of course now
people are able to go out and focus on
other things and spend money in
different ways plus of course you know
there's recessions and there's all sorts
of things going on
um which of course has hit the streaming
sites
um and of course another problem is that
there are so many
um competitors you know we already
mentioned quite a few of them
um there's only there's only enough room
for it's a bit like the old days of um
you know like BBC ITV Channel you know
like a few main ones where of course now
obviously live TV's different from
streaming but there are so many options
that people and that's the problem is is
of course is that
um often you have one show that you
really like or One streaming service but
that's it and then you've got lots and
lots of stuff which yeah it's nice there
but it might not be something that you
would particularly want to to watch and
so
um you know that's the problem
everything's so splintered now
um and I'm a person who still likes the
old days of physical media I like the
fact that you know I I still
occasionally go into there is an HMV
where I'm living which is amazing I
discovered it recently I've got really
nice Center as well and I wanted it and
I saw all the all the shows I liked and
of course you know you've got to pay for
them but that to me is it can't be taken
away and my problem with certain
streaming sites is that you can be a big
fan of some show it's really good and
like every six months a year you go back
you get a replay and then there's been
some kind of um uh Finance issue or some
other rights of copyrights or so let's
go to another company and it's gone and
then for instance it's like someone
coming into your house obviously not
really but like taking your CDs your
your favorite DVD films and like sorry
you can't watch it anymore mate bye and
that's it you've lost it that's why
um I'm still quite Pro
um physical media I think and it's just
nice to it's old-fashioned
um but it's it's strange I barely ever
watch my DVDs anymore I have to admit
barely ever yeah yeah it's uh but I got
Disney plus and it's like that's that's
the best one for me but anyway
let's get on about sure sorry of course
it's the evening so we're going to talk
about um reboots why the bloody hell
does Hollywood seem to love a reboot a
remake a sequel a prequel
um and all this rubbish so is it just
that they're lazy is it just that
they've run out of ideas which is a
comment I get a lot on my channel I I I
personally think it's less lack of
confidence in new ideas
um the fact of the matter is that
they've got a good chance if they go
back to a well-established brand name
that um the people of the old fan base
of the old show or film or whatever can
think oh I remember that show oh this is
a new version let's check it out
um and it's I think personally it's a
lot it's partly lack of creativity
um but I think it's a financial
um asset that it's basically aspect that
it's lack of confidence but you know oh
let's try um remaking V let's try
remaking Battle Star glad to go let's
try almost rebooting Star Trek Star Trek
with the Kelvin um timeline yeah so it's
it's that aspect that's I mean how do
you see it what do you think about it I
don't believe it's a lack of creativity
I I think there are producers out there
and writers that are just as creative as
they ever have been I mean just look at
YouTube and you know there's so many
different ways people can now Express
their creativity and there's some you
know really amazing stuff just because
yeah we're just as creative we always as
but I think there's a maybe a lack of
Confidence from Executives sometimes
like you said to spend a lot of money
even cheap TV shows nowadays cost two
three million dollars an episode yes and
you know the more expensive ones
I mean if we're looking at Stargate
we're looking at anything between 60 and
100 million dollars for 10 episodes yeah
exactly um the new Airbender TV shows
costing 15 million dollars an episode to
produce
um
yeah I mean that's just insane and
obviously we know Lord of the Rings and
rings of Power are what's huge yeah so
there's a lot of money goes on these
things I I think though the hardest
thing for any new show regardless if
it's a reboot whatever it's getting
people interested to watch it
and even if you see like the arc the new
TV show is going to be on sci-fi um
shortly
um all the advertising is from the
makers of Stargate
because they've got to get that hook yes
oh yes I'll try that it's a link I need
something and I think there's an element
of
um we want to feel like we're connected
to it somehow and if there's that
connection through something we've seen
before yeah we're more likely to watch
it again yeah I agreeing too early
um but it is it is a strange thing I
mean um one thing which surprises me is
that often with these streaming sites
they want to have a large amount of
content and of course back in the day
you'd get like with Star Trek you get 26
episodes a season of course now they
tend to make a much more expensive
production per episode but say half of
that even less than that half of that
per season which I always think of it as
a strange contradiction because
um you can do some really good I mean I
I think that Stargate itself
um the SG-1 Atlantis you know I think
they still yes they are a bit dating to
a degree but they still they just look
so good to watch they just it's just the
visual Eye Candy of just the you know
the Stargate whirring into shape or a
gold attack attacking and you know death
gliders and I I loved all that and and I
I'm amazed that they can't find a way of
doing something which still looks good
and it doesn't narrow the amount of per
season but it seems to be like um the
standard Norm these days that it is big
big episodes for fewer episodes per
season so strange there's um I I think
when we're talking about streaming
services I think there's a there's a
double-edged sword there because I think
in in one respect there's an advantage
that they can and I think they're only
just starting to really realize this
that they can release episodes any way
they like they can do as many episodes
as they like so they're not set to
having to do like 22 Episodes to fit the
calendar sort of thing of the old
networks so they always had to be set to
this many episodes um sometimes they did
12 and they would have like two
different series but mostly they were
like right we want a season of blah blah
blah you gotta do 22 Episodes or 24
depending on whether it's the spring or
Autumn because at Autumn they tend to do
a few less because they then go into a
Christmas
um specials and things
yeah but on a streaming service you can
do however many episodes you need for
the story
so again going back to Stargate
apparently what Amazon have actually
asked for
um in their brief when they've sort of
sent they've sent a brief out to
companies to say we want you to pitch
for this and they've asked for 8 to 12
episodes as an initial season right and
then be creative can then sort of say
well our story needs 11.
they just dropped a bonus episode at the
end that no one knew about I never saw
that I didn't know they did that that's
quite interesting yeah you can't do that
on a network but you can on a streaming
service so I mean there's double edge so
but I don't honestly know why they've
gone into this formula of like
10 episodes
yeah I mean it's like I always do now
and I don't know why it's like with Star
Wars and all came out the first um two
or three episodes released at once on
the same day uh I think I think for that
show it's because it was more it was
like that show had like three episode
arcs and then it would go to the next
Arc I think that's partly why they did
it but I should say they could never
have done that in the olden days of the
network because it just doesn't work
that way
um so I mean let's ask about
um you know obviously there are remakes
and things like that and I was thinking
before I joined today about the best
remakes that I've come across how but
don't leave most of them for me don't
work
um I would say that one of the most
successful remakes and you probably
would agree I assume maybe one it's
probably Battlestar Galactica the Remake
I think it's the I think it could argue
it's the only successful remake I agree
um I um
if we're ignoring movies so just just TV
shows yeah okay um and obviously we're
only talking about sci-fi because we're
a Sci-Fi channel sure
um but I
I mean I actually struggle to create a
very long list of remakes like like full
proper remakes where they've pretended
the original didn't happen a hard reboot
I could think of a few but I know what
you mean it's not a there's not loads
massive in sci-fi I know I agree about
it I mean you I think people think there
are more because it feels like it's
almost happening you know but a lot of
the time their continuations rather than
full hard reboots but my list is like
Battlestar Galactica Lost in Space yes I
believe Knight Rider did one back in the
90s that's not horrible I heard it was
terrible yes I've heard of it
yeah
but V uh V was a remake
Charmed
um never saw that but yeah I know no I
didn't either but um and I really
struggled after that to really think of
many
um continuations
[Music]
okay so I've got to say that the British
ones that are remakes I can think of are
the Triffids which is
about 2009. that was a remake
um survivors which was made in the 70s
got remade in about the early 2000s
that's two yeah
um what else have got remade they're the
two I can think of off the cuff
um Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy has
been remade that was remade as a film
wasn't it yeah uh yeah it was a BBC Two
series and then they've made a film yeah
yeah that's another one films have had a
few sort of like reboots and they think
like they always try to make Americans
always try to make these stupid films
into comedies
Baywatch was awful I watched Hutch was
almost oh yes yeah I heard about that I
like the old shows but I just saw um
like the poster for like Starsky and
Hutch with um there's Adam Sandler in
there it was Owen Wilson which was um no
it's the one that looks like Adam
Sandler but isn't Adam Sandler he's
always angry oh [__] he was in mystery
man
um ask her to bug Us Now isn't it yeah
somebody in the comments will normally
tell us
a fella is in Mystery Men or whatever
um him Along Came Polly and
um I've got my phone in
I was about to get mine but I think he
beat me to it so I'll let you know um so
but yeah
um
and Owen Wilson wasn't it I think oh
Wilson yeah um
so
um but yeah that was awful The A Team I
actually quite liked to be honest but
the Dukes of Hazard was really bad
Johnny Knoxville
um and the other fella
um
it was just awful and they've tried to
me about lots of times over the years
and it just does not work well I think
part I know like I said summaries aren't
quite sci-fi so I apologize for going
slightly off topic but I think the
reason why some of these don't work is
because they were a product of the time
they worked when they were made and the
world has changed a bit quite a lot
actually and when they try to emulate
for a new audience based on how an
original show was pitched and agreed and
made it doesn't work that's a strange
thing with Battlestar Galactica
um the 70s Show I like the 70s Show I
even watched Glasgow 1980 so that's how
much of a fan I was flying bikes and
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
the Cylon and Halloween and everything
else as well but
um when the remotes Ronald D Moore did
it I think and of course he was on Star
Trek um they just made such an
interesting spin on the original they
made it very very
different but in a way that's just
really really worked it just it felt
contemporary but it was also
recognizable to the original fan base
now I don't know because I'm not a huge
Battlestar classic fan what the classic
fans thought of the new show whether it
was like when the next Generation came
out I know this was um it was a
continuation rather than a remake so
it's slightly different but do you know
about the Original Classic whether it
was um uh well received by classic fans
when it was first announced it wasn't
popular but whenever anything's
announced like that it's not popular
when the next generation was announced
people went crazy trekkies went nuts
um but yeah it was not unpopular but
again Battlestar Galactica was a little
bit before the internet age
so it just sort of nipped in before
um yeah a lot of social media so I think
it got away with a lot
um
but but yeah I don't think it was
massively thick but the main thing I
think the focus went on Starbuck
Henry yeah which was really really
clever uh idea and Katie sack up was
really really good as the female
Starbuck I liked it but I think that
took a lot of the Heat yeah I think that
was a clever way of doing it um
especially when so when Dirk Benedict
came out and went how can they make
Starbucks a woman and was was you know
like like [__] steering a little bit
um and then I I can only imagine the
executive producer so somebody got hold
of him and then he actually met Katie
suck off and he actually went ah okay
this is actually brilliant no he
mellowed but I didn't know that I could
understand though because he would be
defensive from the fact that he was
Starbuck yeah so you could understand
that it's going to be
um but then um I wasn't um the guy that
played Apollo going to be involved with
some remake of Battle Star or something
um the guy played Paula was it serious
yeah
play this politician or something didn't
he or but I think at some point before
the Battle Star remake he was wanting to
do some remake or continuation of
Battlestar himself and it didn't happen
and I think in the end he still appeared
as you say as the politician in the
remake
um and he was fighting this character
was interesting so
um it is interesting how you know um
sometimes even actors and stars of these
shows they really get um heavily
involved in trying to bring these shows
back whether it be a remake or more
probably more likely to be a
continuation
um which is um wasn't it the guy that
played John Shepard in Atlantis he was
the one that really that he really
pushed against Lance's coming back
trying to buy it he tried that's right I
can't do the same but yeah yeah
um but yeah oh God I do know his name
it's gone but yeah as well you know what
I mean though yeah yeah he no he tried
to actually he publicly tried to buy the
franchise from MGM to to to produce a
new series
um obviously MGM weren't interested but
um so focus on Battlestar Galactica from
it then we'll talk about why we think
other remakes haven't worked why why did
Battlestar Galactica work
and I will say very quickly as well I
think Battlestar Galactica wandered
towards the end
yeah uh the fourth season a lot of
people said that it did lose lose the
track of what it was doing a bit in that
last season I actually didn't mind the
last season
um I think it worked um combination of
things like I said before it was a very
unique take on a familiar named brand of
sci-fi show it had a really really good
cast it had really good special effects
the Battlestar Galactica itself was
really cool
um and of course we had to even have
like the Battlestar Pegasus at one point
as well
um and um
I like the fact that it did Embrace even
though it was a remake it like you had
some classic silence in some of the
later episodes
um yeah and and I I just think that
it was unique enough that I don't know
how do I ask that question
it just worked I don't know why it just
worked it's just something about it the
way it came across the way it was
written
worked I really can't answer any better
than that really I'm sorry but I just it
just worked I think they had um I think
they walked a really fine line between
um the original and the
um
and I think like for example they had
the the new sort of fighter didn't they
the Viper at the start of the thing and
it was a different design
new ones yeah and then they brought in
the old one to sort of and then they
they very cleverly wrote that in and
said oh well all the new ones are
digital and they've been blasted and
we've got so they they had they had
enough sense
and the Galactica looked kind of the
same so I think they walk a really fine
line between updating and keeping the
original and they did the same with the
story yeah they very cleverly
um had a story that was that was it was
core the same as the original
um and you know they were trying to a
book but they added enough that it was
different enough that it wasn't just
basically you know recreating the
original so but I think Ronald D Moore
particularly he was very very clever in
in that respect and I think a lot of
other remakes and things and
particularly I'm thinking maybe movies
and stuff haven't worked
um because somebody will come in and
they'll say right well we have to change
it we have to make it and they go maybe
too far or they change things that don't
need to be changed well as we talk about
movies although it's although we're
sticking with TV the the prime example
for me is probably the Kelvin Star Trek
films you know how they did try to you
know the recast everything and they had
a new Enterprise and the Klingons looked
different and I I'm actually I don't
mind that Kelvin um films as much as
some people
um I just see them as their their own
thing but it was a reboot uh and it
really was
um and that this is the problem I mean
some people are even saying that
potentially although it's a prequel it's
like do you think it's strange new
worlds as a sort of reboot because
they've redesigned the Enterprise it's
different about that I think they're in
danger of becoming a reboot at the
moment I hate prequels
um I say everybody there's like 50
people watching right now they're all
gonna go yeah Jamie Hayes pretty cool
they generally piss on Canon and I they
wind me up strange the world is really
at risk of
basically remaking the Original Series
right they're not very careful and they
are already rewriting the history
um
the characters are so brilliant I don't
think anyone will really care too much I
do think they have redesigned the
Enterprise a little bit but I think they
did quite do it on purpose because it's
supposed to look like a slightly earlier
version
at the Enterprise like it were to then
be refit to the TOs era yeah okay and
then refit again to the movie version
It's supposed to look older wouldn't it
be great in the very last episode of
strategy was it comes in for a refit and
then it looks just like the original
series Enterprise it comes out the space
that space dock you've got the original
bridge and the original sound effects
actually which are still using this and
I would love that that would be a real
for a geek like me that would be like
yes that'd be great it would happen
though well I think with modern CGI and
stuff as well it can't it's difficult to
do and it'll look right they can they
can make the ship look
more realistic man
well I mean the white look the same a
lot of people's said how when you saw
the original Enterprise Bridge or it's
actually the citizenship Defiance in the
episode two-part episode in a mirror
Darkly on Enterprise how it looks just
so cool because it was lit differently
and although it was like a 40 year old
design when that was made
um it still looked really to me at least
I thought it looked really good because
it was much darker lit it was different
shadows and it just gave it that kind of
extra sort of like it's fitted with
Canon but it also because you know
filming techniques now that lighting is
different it just really worked so it's
interesting isn't it I don't know yeah I
think there's one like Technologies
um Advanced so far though as well that a
lot of Whenever You remake as anything
sci-fi from like 20 years ago even like
the Next Generation we watch the Next
Generation now and you're sort of like
that computers slow as [__]
um
yes our Technology's overtook it yeah so
then when they make a prequel like in
strange new worlds now they're sort of
like well if we use the same technology
you know we flick buttons and things as
the original series from 1969 this kind
of looks stupid because we've already
got much better you know big like Block
cards that have data thing they they put
otherwise it used to go in the panels
yes yes we're going to look like dicks
so they've got to change some bits that
has to be yeah you have to do that for
the audience yes I understand that
completely and I do think actually
although they've had to I think on the
whole they've actually done quite well
as you've already said absolutely
respects in Canon like I said it's not a
proper reboot but it's it's like a real
bit which is why we're discussing in
this episode yeah
um and um yeah I think for one that show
Works
um but of course it would be a soft
reboot the current stranger was because
anything with like where you've got the
story existed but you've got different
actors playing the characters that is a
reboot it's a different sort of reboot
but it's a you know it's a it's a soft
reboot so
um but Star Trek and Canon
Star Trek's always danced around Canon
yeah it's never it's never been
everything
always has some contradiction because
it's such a huge tapestry of episodes
and storylines I mean they tried to hold
it together but sometimes things fail uh
and you'll get someone like me so I'll
remember that episode in season two
episode three we're strange like that
that's that character shouldn't look you
know you know you gotta you can't be
that set in stone I think that um you've
said the frequency of the warp bubble
was two three five nine five
yeah I know and and I think people need
to carve down and things like that
because sometimes the story and I think
we said this and even your podcast
sometimes the story just needs to happen
calm down it just you know just enjoy it
just enjoy it Let It Go just Let It Go
through and and yeah
yeah I think there's a line that you
should respect because we are Geeks yeah
and you know we do you know so like we
know how many decks there are in the
Enterprise you really should focus on
that
there was 27 decks and then later on
they said that we just captured the Borg
in deck 29 or something yeah it's 25.7
29 or more yeah it was something like
that I know that it was something
different and they actually there was a
discrepancy in the film and I'm I need
to get alive sometimes so I do apologize
oh no I'm I'm in the I'm in the cinema
going it's only got 24 decks
could just throw that guy off a bridge
downwards on Deck 29 and I'm getting
angry in the movie I came out of the
first JJ Abrams movie Furious uh good
they [__] made the Enterprise water
powered and I was really yeah it's like
a brewery wasn't it it was like a
Distillery or something it was the
engine it was like what that was that it
was like yeah it was really quite
bizarre um not a Star Trek movie
basically they're just not Star Trek
movies they're good films and they're
entertainment and if you love a lens
flare oh they're amazing and but they're
not they're not Star Treks well that was
probably Discovery that's the discovery
took on a lot of the the mantle of um
uh the Covenant Universe films and like
the first two I was going to say this
you I don't think you've seen the later
Seasons but if you look at the turbo
lift shafts in the later Seasons they
are huge you see a ship a terminative
going down and it's like it's like a
city
and it's like yeah I know what you mean
yeah I've seen it why would they do that
I do think sometimes like you don't need
to do that whether it's being a reboot
or yeah
yeah it's just it there's so many bits
in Star Trek that we could
get angry about particularly disco
um that aren't aren't worth it really
but um
so we say so yeah balthal Galactica I
think it worked because they they walked
the walk that line right um between
changing it I actually think another
series that I actually really enjoyed
but people generally didn't
um was the remake of Lost in Space
um I preferred that to the original the
original for me was a bit too campy I
like the original but I for some reason
I watched the the Remake uh I think only
had a couple years ago it finished but I
thought it was really solid actually I
thought it was really well made thing so
um yeah and I think I think maybe the
similar thing there though they they had
the original story they changed it so
that it made sense because the original
story didn't really and not with what we
know about sort of technology and things
now I think we'd all we'd all sort of of
we could all how has it got lost
basically but the Jupiter was kind of
similar they kept the designs kind of
similar they got the the robot was great
yes danger Will Robinson they'd still
you know that so they brought enough of
these little things in for us to go ah I
love that bit without going you know too
far
um I think the only downside of Lost in
Space was that it's maybe a little
boring
um it was maybe they could have sped up
the pace a little bit
so um
I mean how many episodes did they make
because it was it was um was it three C
three seasons I actually did three
seasons or four I think it's three
seasons and it's like 10 or 12 episodes
of season so I only made like 30 hours
um and I liked it I just think it was
um
it it was a little slow at places
um but I like the actors I liked the I
think I thought the special effects were
great um it cost a lot of money to make
that's the only reason Netflix didn't
make another one
um but
um so yeah I mean
I I read I really loved it you know it's
like um
again I thought it was clever and they
walked that line beautifully to me that
was a successful reboot remake that was
another one that actually one of the few
that did work I have to ask you did you
uh Richie watch the original V series
the mini series from the 80s
very well I love the original the
original series I loved it I absolutely
adored it
um and of course they made the remake
with um the actress of plays is it Valor
on this G1 Marina Marina Barack Barack
yeah yeah who's who's uh um
um I thought it was
do you know I did watch it at the time
um I couldn't tell you a damn thing that
happened in it now it was very
forgettable and I'm not 100 certain it
made sense
um the original I always thought was so
clever and I thought the special effects
stand up even today because they kept
them really simple
um the the newer storyline it tried to
it's tried to go around the same
storyline I remember like the camps and
stuff that they had the alien camps on
the surface and things and and that how
some people turned against it and stuff
like that so I remember this column was
the fifth column that was called yeah
but generally speaking
um it was just very very forgettable and
I'm not surprised at all it didn't work
it's a shame it is a shame that um
I mean with v i mean the bee had
originally had the um the mini-series
then it had the final battle then it had
one season afterwards which was just
like 20 sort of Standalone episodes and
by that point you could tell that a lot
of the actors were slowly moving on as
the show continued and um and you could
tell if the budget was pretty uh basic
um but the original mini-series I
remember I think it was on I was no I'm
not a sports fan but I know you're quite
a football fan but I remember the the
Olympics I think it came out in 1984
this year my age and
um it was
um
One Summer and what they did it was V
the mini series was shown after Olympic
Games or something and I never forgot it
because you didn't get a lot of sci-fi
on ITV in the 80s kind of thing and I
fell in love with it and ever since then
I've adored it so when we had the Remake
um to me I don't know just something
just wasn't there I didn't like the
design of the ships either no that's not
a big thing but I I recently I loved the
white shuttles and the fighters from the
original series which I know it doesn't
matter but I'm quite geeky about my
ships
um yeah and it just it just didn't stand
out it didn't kind of I can't even
remember it that well even though I've
seen it twice I didn't dislike it but I
don't it didn't have that
um that Battlestar had as a remake it's
strange isn't it and yeah and another
thing about Battlestar was that it stood
out
um creatively so much as well I mean you
can tell how great it was so many awards
for the special effects and the look of
the show and the you know everything
they put into it and and you can tell
that there's so many shows have copied
it since
Stargate SGU copied it
um
V just didn't do that it didn't stand
out at all there was nothing in it
really that was memorable and that's the
that's the problem and I watched it at
the time I can remember that there's the
blonde girl in it who I can't tell you
but she's been in a few things since
she's in some werewolf show after it and
but I think that's none of the character
stuff I personally Love Marina but I
think that she's forgettable she has a
short hair oh my God I'm a sucker for a
girl short hair
um
it's just you know nothing could save
that show because creatively it just
wasn't
no it just wasn't imaginative enough
um
but you know
it is a shame that
I say this though as well that they make
a lot of remakes and I can reboots and
things but Hollywood and stuff do make a
lot of new TV shows as well yeah I think
you think a lot of people think oh God
it's another rebook it's really really I
do think there's a place for a remake
and a reboot the biggest shows though in
the last few years have been original
stuff based on books maybe but original
the biggest sci-fi shows or biggest
fantasy shows Game of Thrones that's
that wasn't a remake I know they've now
made a prequel but
um stranger things you know it was
original
um that was based on books was it I'm
not sure I mean this is this is the film
side of things but we've got to talk
about this what do you think of June the
original and June the remake
I know certainly half the Remake so far
I've ever seen
I I really I enjoyed the original but it
was
um it is hard watching because it's it's
quite slow
um and obviously it's dated
yeah which doesn't always it's not
always a factor for me it's gonna be
made it's um
um hi
um your Channel's roughly on one of my
favorite YouTube channels keep up all
the good work and thanks for the work
you do thank you sir thank you and
you've yeah he's always is if every live
show is absolutely brilliant nice one
brilliant um and thank you so much for
the for the little donation every little
helps I'm like Tesco's
um
one I'm going down to four days a week
in my proper job soon
okay yeah so that's going to be my uh so
yeah every little helps
um but yeah so um what the hell was I
talking about can't remember June
um it's a bit slow but oh my God it was
beautifully made
um dated yep the the new version again
it's a bit slow because that's the style
and that's how the book was written and
it's very descriptive very thing um and
everything and there's a lot going on
um but God it's beautifully made
and officially it's beautiful yes I I
saw it at the IMAX I I thoroughly
suggest anybody if you just watch this
at home on a streaming service
um you
you know you you don't get the impact
you need to go and watch a cinema or the
4K or the or preferably the IMAX right
um and it is astonishing
um
it's like Avatar or something like that
one those sort of big films where you
really need to see the best possible
form okay and we did all we're going to
the cinema every chance we get or they
will close
yeah I I you know what I've not been uh
since before the pandemic
um the last film I saw was Star Wars the
rise of Skywalker uh and that was 2019
so
um I just I know you're right I mean the
cinema movie industry
um but mind you the Avatar is um the
second one has just passed two billion
which is pretty good
um
two movies go over 150 billion
so you know that's not too bad that's
not too shabby that'll do the uh the
cinema Market a bit of a boost but as
you say
um I mean do you I mean I've decided
that's very quickly so we'll go slightly
off topic but do you think that the
cinema industry is in danger of
imploding at some point soon or what do
you think will happen with that I think
there'll just be a correction like there
was in the 80s and 90s that there was a
lot of Cinemas the ones that have a
profitable clothes and they need to
change like the cinema by me has changed
and it's took out like half the seats
and they put in these glorious reclining
seats that you can see
they're amazing and so you only get like
I've got maybe 100 people in there
um and it's quite expensive to go right
um but I get the I pay for that thing
was like 15 pound a month and you go as
often as you like which makes it a lot
more you know affordable sort of thing
um but
those ones Will Survive and the ones
that don't keep up will probably die
like they did in the 80s and 90s
um but I think there will be a direction
of people like going out and but it
needs to be an event as well there needs
to be a restaurant there needs to be a
bar that needs to be you know it needs
to be a night out
the only thing I'm slightly worried
about is that nowadays we have these 4K
TVs massive screens lovely surround
sound good speakers in your own home you
know and you have to worry about someone
I mean one thing I can't stand if I go
to cinema is if someone is is like crazy
through food like crisps and hot dogs
and it's it's like it's been like two
hours just munching and munching and
munching I'm not very good with exterior
noises like that so
um but I just I mean that's just like
anything I mean if they if you're saying
that the seating remains is the way that
they're designed now is a bit more
spacious a bit more you're you're part
of the cinema to watch properly then
okay I think you're right that would
certainly be a bit of a boost those are
the ones that will survive I think the
ones that are odina that's what they're
Odin do in there they're getting rid of
all those uncomfortable seats
they're adapting to a new market and a
new way of entertainment making people
more comfortable and stuff and but but
yeah you'll still get idiots in there
and I still got it it's a little law of
averages isn't it you're going to get
somebody who's gonna be annoying
so you answered the phone in the movie
the other week um hello I know I'm in a
movie and it goes yes you're in a movie
put the phone down
I'll be TV where he used to go hello
like that kind of thing yeah but it was
like that and I was like God mate you
have never had more people hate you this
quickly ever I mean that's just like
it it was astonishing the hatred in that
room and he didn't get up and walk out
he just sat there oh yeah I mean I do a
lot of driving for my jobs I do and you
get some people who just they just don't
give a damn and it's just like the law
of averages right I can't talk that
you're going to get some people who just
disregard what you consider to be a
normal civilized practices
um so let me ask you um I suppose we we
have mentioned it but we had to talk
about about because this is a star get
channel
um let's just say Stargate is properly
created a new Target series and it's a
reboot what other pros and cons you
foresee if and that I don't want it to
be a reboot we both want it to be a
continuation it's got 20 years of
history or whatever what would you like
if they got to go that direction to see
I have talked about this before but I
mean it's if they did a hard reboot
where they pretended like nothing
happened which was we were at risk of
yeah um and we still I still think we're
generally at risk of the longer we wait
I think the more risk of a hard reboot
we are right um but there are advantages
and this isn't going to be popular I'm
sorry but there are advantages to a hard
reboot
by the end of sg1 humanity was so
Advanced you know we had spaceships
you know and we were that we had all of
the Asgard weaponry and shields we were
the baddest
you know we had the baddest Fleet out
there you know we would kick anyways at
the Lucian Airlines would have no chance
against us they just had attacks
whatever we would just wipe before them
so we all of a sudden are the dominant
species in the galaxy
all of a sudden it's not Stargate
anymore it's Star Trek yeah and we're 10
years on again don't forget so we're
we're 12 years old since SGU
so a hard reboot yeah five advantages in
that you can start again
um clean slate
what okay even though my head says that
that's not a terrible idea my heart goes
if you do that I will burn your house
down Jeff Bezos and that's for legal
reasons that's not a threat
um okay
for me to reach 20K thank you Shelley I
will do my best my lady
um 4 000 to go so please guys if you are
new to the channel like subscribe and
hit that Bell notification share this
video wherever the hell you want Shelly
is um Shelly's our Facebook lady and
she's just phenomenal
I sent her a um she's not a Stargate fan
but I sent her a quote
um with a Stargate load go on and let's
let's do one more trip through the old
orifice and didn't explain it
and she's still doing stuff for you on
Facebook I'm surprised about that he's
got a picture
God love her she's she's amazing she's
genuinely Shelly I love you I love you
very much stop stop giving money to the
channel or else you do enough
well let's just have what do we think um
so sorry yeah so that's my thinking if
they did a hard reboot those are the
positives yeah okay but as I said
massive negatives in that there's so
much story they'd just be pissing away
and you know so much happened so much
there was such a big part of my life you
know this is my favorite TV show for
like 15 years you know it's
it would be difficult if they did it if
they did a hard reboot it would be very
difficult
I I got into it in about 2000
um and I started getting the DVDs once a
month and I just fell in love with this
series I think it was on Sky one at one
point and I saw this really low quality
and of course then you know get a bite
um to ask what you see if they were to
if it were to be remade or rebooted kind
of thing I mean first of all you wonder
who though would actually cast as the
main characters whether it would be
another Daniel Jackson Another Jack
O'Neill or whether it be something
slightly different I assume they'd have
to have the same characters and then of
course would you then have all the
um antagonists would you have the gold
again with their eyes still glow which
you still have similar looking ships
Mike but the biggest geeky thing is what
they would do how they would redesign
the Stargate because they technically
they redesign it three times in the
three shows
um but I everything to me says that
there is still a huge fan base and so
really
um they they've got to find a way I
think of doing a continuation and maybe
slowly easing into it maybe they can
sort of do like episode one is after or
doing universe and then it would like
they could look like a fine Ava jump in
the first few episodes so it's to catch
up with our real time something where
you can have a transitional thing so
that you'll get you got 2023 you know
what's happened since 2011. you know
what the Stargate program is whether
it's in the public or knowledge that to
me it can't it can't work as a reboot
although I still think it's a
possibility that as we've already
discussed so I don't know I mean like I
said
um
let's just hope it if it does come back
it's going to be a continuation what do
we think of the core because I mean the
bats are Galactica where they said they
got the core things right now they kept
the Viper they kept the battle style of
the same the general storyline so
there's they kept the core things yeah
right and that appeased the fans what
and guys get into the comments as well
and tell me what you think I did that's
a good question that's a good question
the Stargate that they must not ignore
um if the Stargate has got to look like
water when it opens up I know it sounds
dark but that is such a iconic visual
aspect of Stargate it's the physical
opening of the gate I think they've got
to do it so it's it's similar I think
well it was more medieval in later sg1
um I personally think that
the aspect of the early seasons in the
original movie really worked because it
was based on a lot of real events in
life like the pyramids and all the all
the things that are involved so I would
like it to remain Egyptian based what do
you think about that would you like that
I think so because I mean it was so much
based around the Ancient Aliens
Theory
who loves the Ancient Aliens stuff yeah
and every bloody film he makes
um
it was so intertwined particularly like
you said in the early series I mean when
they when they then started to do the TV
series and they started to visit other
planets and they were like
snapshots in history so you'd have
medieval ones you'd have you know
um Tibetan you that you'd have
everything that's right yes Egyptian
um if you actually think about that
logically that make no bloody sense it
didn't but
yeah I mean it didn't yeah it still
worked didn't it it's a strange thing
because it was fantasy it's fancy and
you ignore it I mean technology as well
is like it all looks like Stone but it's
actually oh if you just remove the
Snuggles the crystals again makes no
sense at all but you just go with it
don't you but you just love it you just
love it
um so I hope they don't mess around with
that too much I think but I do think
yeah I think a gate shape the gate
General design can't mess with I hope
they keep the sound effects as well
because I love the sound the Stargate
darling yeah again and that's an easy
way to keep fans on board that was a big
sound guy I love Sci-Fi Sounds to look
distinctive and I taught you before
about in the future we should do top 10
Sci-Fi Sounds but yeah it's got to be
that sound of the death gliders star
weapons yeah I don't know I I just don't
I can't see it working in a reboot I
think it would it would just you know
unless I really gets it they really know
what it is but my fear is that someone
will be aware of it they'll look at
about 10 episodes and they'll
reinterpret it based on what they think
it should be rather than getting what
Stargate is and only us fans and the
people who like Brad writing they know
what it is
that's the problem well my um the one
thing that keeps me positive is that
they're not going to reboot it is not
just because the sources that I speak to
constantly telling the Amazon don't want
to reboot it they've always said there
was three plans and the third plan was
hard reboot if everything else failed
but they always talked about that they
know there'd be a backlash yeah but
Roland Emerick did an interview got
eight or nine months ago now and he was
talking about
um
back in 2015 they were going to do
another film based on the original movie
so they were actually going to even
bring in James Spader and Kurt Russell
to actually do it wouldn't have been
amazing oh wow yeah right I'd love to
have seen that I would have been hard it
was going to ignore the TV series and be
a direct sequel to the movie
my next question was does that suggest
in some ways that the SG-1 series is
almost like a reboot of the original
movie
it is in a way but it's not it's a
reimagining in lots of ways it is a
continuation it's a direct continuation
of the movie
um
it would have been more of a
discontinuity then because it was going
its own tangent if they made that second
movie that's what I'm saying well there
was always apparently American Dean
Devlin always had a Trilogy in mind and
that's what they wanted to make they
wanted me to challenge and then um a
couple of years ago they were asked to
say well would would you like to just
MGM were actually looking at maybe we
completely do that trilogy again just
like hard reboot start again do those
Trilogy movies and Roland Emerick was
very clear and he said Amazon and MGM
that all they care about is the TV
audience they don't care about them
audience okay I don't know them and that
reassured me and I'm like all right good
if Amazon is saying the TV audience what
matters that means sg1 SGA and SG you've
got faith in that in that what matters
right that's interesting well it's us
that fans of the TV series so that
reassures me
um that there can't be a hard reboot
um and there are lots of ways to can do
things my only issue is I don't see how
we get a big like sg1
they'll go anywhere do anything type
series that explores the universe in a
lot of detail because as I said I think
that'll be a bit star trekky
but there are some things they can
explore you know and somebody mentioned
in the comments a little while ago and I
I did a little series a little while ago
thinking about if I was going to do this
how would I create a new Stargate series
and I said I want to make the furlings
as the antagonist which you've never
seen and explore the feelings yeah so
yeah one of the fifth rate is one of the
fifth the four races or something yeah
yeah did we see in one episode The
Comedy one where they look like Ewoks or
something they were like yeah yeah there
was some funny aspect to one episode
that was just Jack O'Neill imagine you
know that's that wasn't real
um but but yeah so and we we think we
might have seen them once or twice they
hinted one to two episodes and we saw
the technology once or twice yes like
the weather changing device and things
um but we never actually saw them in any
you know I think so I I think that would
be really interesting to explore
um there's obviously the answers
answering Stargate Universe there's
answering where the Atlantis is that
there's lots of things they can explore
but I think sorry I was gonna say what
might be the interesting aspect as well
as Ascension what about that kind of
aspect where um you know there could be
something where
um you know people are trying to ascend
to a different playment existence that
we had the um
uh what was the race did those come in
there what was it um who are the ones
who did this agency yeah the Ancients
did that I just think that might be an
interesting maybe not a focus of the
show but that could be a very
interesting aspect where
um it's it's known that you know the the
Ancients did Ascend I don't know just
something
an ancients prequel for me would be the
only time I would actually accept a
prequel I would actually love an
ancients prequel it's something that's
based a million years before because it
can't piddle on Canon because it would
be way before sg1 and it can actually
add to what we've seen
um it could explain a lot of things a
lot of episodes we think there are so
many ways they could do an ancients
prequel and that it would be really
exciting because in the Arc of Truth we
did see a flashback to where the guy was
actually drawing the first star getting
us an idea at one point exactly which I
thought was a nice thing so yeah I'm
interested in that I certainly would so
I don't know we have to see how it goes
I guess okay just before before we call
it in the evening then because we're
we're at the hour mark okay which is
generally where I try to
um to end this because you know there's
only something you can do I'm old
when we're talking about reboots and um
I think um Trek guy
um I've forgotten your bloody name uh
track gate mentioned it a little while
ago the Babylon 5 reboot plans
so they're still tentative it still
might happen
um but with HBO's issues at the moment
it's a I would I would argue it's
probably about
50 50 at best but um but again do you
think that's a TV show
the design
Babylon 5 is another show which has a
huge Rich tapestry of characters and
story arcs and things like that and for
me Babylon 5 worked because it was on
for Five Seasons it had a couple of
other things as well
um and it had time to
get the stories to where they went if
we're talking back to what we said about
the fact that production of shows now is
a lot shorter there's only 10 episodes
per season or something I would have
thought that it would be difficult
um to do a show like that
um because they would have to sort of
cut out a lot of elements which made
Babylon 5 Babylon five I suppose it's
possible what do you think
well for one thing at the moment the CW
have got first dibs and if it goes on
the CW we could get 22 episode full
season okay
um which would have to be whatever
that's right well you say that the
budget would be
probably the same as 10 episodes would
get on a streaming service so they're
gonna have to stretch the budget a lot
but the other strength is that JMS is
actually writing it and creating it so
you've got the original Creator still in
charge which is a big strength okay I
wasn't aware of that that is a major
factor that is a really good Pro thing
the other thing is I think Babylon 5 was
one of those series
though that in an Ideal World
you wouldn't reboot it in an ideal
that's what I was thinking yeah
um you would go back and you would
digitally remaster it like they did with
Star Wars and you would redo the special
effects and you would
um
yeah well yeah so do something like that
but that's not they're never going to do
that though because it would cost a
fortune and
although it is getting cheaper I mean
I've seen the remastered SG-1 and um I
know Seasons nine and ten were HD but
seasons one to eight and that show the
picture quality got better as the show
went on buyback season four
yeah it's not it's not bad it's not HTTP
they've done a way that it's not too you
know they had this sort of like effect
where they smooth up the edges and you
look like almost everyone looks like
christened from red to war they've got
this weird kind of angular smoothed out
features they just don't look human
um but I thought sg1 which of course is
a widescreen mate show which would
probably would help them out yeah it's
done well
um
just reformatting though I mean
literally with Babylon five red you have
to do all the CGI [__] and that that's
for sure because that was the weakness
of the show was the special effects
because it's very early in CGI yeah
exactly
um but that's not that's there's no that
nobody's gonna pay for that
um I I just think
the characters were so amazing this is a
bit like rebooting Firefly for me
it's very difficult to do because the
characters and the actors I mean were so
um
so well cast it's very difficult to do
again and don't get me wrong it's not
impossible because they're still
brilliant character actors today like
they were yesterday
you've got to get fans on board really
bloody quickly because they're going to
go into people will watch The Babylon 5
reboot but they're going to be watching
it
with the original in mind with Jakarta
and actually highly critical of it then
because of that yeah and they're going
to turn and like I said if they ever got
around to and luckily Disney have got
enough sense that even though they've
looked at rebooting Firefly they seem to
the people I speak to seem to say that
they're not going to do it at the moment
at least because they can't figure out
how to do it and not piss everyone off
right
um but the problem is
if they do it
people are going to go into it
remembering Nathan Fillion and blah blah
and and if and if it's if it doesn't
catch them really really quickly they'll
turn on it yeah exactly and it'll fail
and I think Babylon 5 if they if they do
it right because this the core story I
think is great with the shadows and
everything else and and I I'd love to
see what JMS will do with it and
obviously he's got a story idea he
really wants to tell and I trust him
um I bought oh man it's risky
well this just goes back to what I'm
sorry
I finished but I was quick to say but
it's the same as if Brad Wright was
getting involved with the new Stargate
series I would feel you know you
mentioned in that um JMS is doing the
new Babylon it's a huge plus Point
already you know that that's about to
give it some credibility of it going
through because us as fans will be
looking for that and seeing whether he
can create the stuff that the magic he
made in the 90s so reassure a lot of
fans that that it's going to be all
right I think it'll calm down a lot of
the internet shouting which which
the haters and the you know the hate
baiters whatever on on YouTube can kill
a TV show really quickly I mean look at
what it did to
um Quantum Leap and it's actually I've
watched I've watched the first season of
Quantum Leap now
um it's all right I've seen them about
the first four or five of the new series
it's okay I I don't love it I don't
dislike it it's all right yeah
once he starts remembering in the
there's a little bit more intrigued
stuff towards the end of the first 10
episodes It's actually good okay I've
not got that yet I'm not gonna yeah the
Cliffhanger at the end is actually quite
good
um but
um but if you listen to the people on
YouTube you'd think it was just an
absolute [__] showing it's not it's an
okay show but it really killed it you
know it's it's first it's viewing
figures have actually grown people
didn't it's getting renewed though isn't
it I heard it's getting renewed I think
it looked like um they've had the second
half of the first season extended so if
one from tennis
renewal yet and I think it will depend
how it does when it's syndicated abroad
all right it's well known The Originals
what well known so I would have thought
it's going to give it at least a
positive start so I have to say yeah and
but again they've had enough sense to
make that a continuation not a hard
reboot which I think is is with sensible
yeah because
um Al's wife is in it
um which are the same mattresses in it
as well
yeah of course yeah I thought that's a
lovely callback as well so yeah fingers
crossed 30 days for that series but I'll
be watching yeah and but let's say to go
back to why does Hollywood do it though
I think we get lots of new stuff and we
do we get lots of new TV series new
movies new projects we get remakes and
things I would love to see a Highlander
remake I think we're due with new
special effects and things I think that
is the one movie that I always think
about and I think [__] they really
need Henry Cavill is supposed to be
signed on to do it and they need to
crack on and do it because it would be
brilliant
um
let me tell you a very quick story
before we go um yeah I had a friend at
work who was a big fan of the actor who
played TANF in starga sg1 who also
appeared on Highlander and she was
actually
um she was in British Columbia and she
actually knew people who worked on those
shows and she actually ended up in the
Stargate uh Studios and she was into
Target command and she was even a
Stargate fan and I was so jealous of the
fact that because at the time the actual
place Talent was in it and I just
thought he was so lucky to imagine being
on those sets properly the high in the
background
but I never forgot that so there we go
through competitions when sg1 was being
filmed I used to run competitions
appear on Stargate but yeah that's been
a Fast book I say
just to round it up then basically why
do they is it laziness or is it because
they run out of ideas
I don't think so I personally I think
they do remix and reboots because one we
like them
we like prequels because we like to know
what happened beforehand we like to know
what happened before an idea of a
successful thing yeah exactly it's an
easy way to hook us and I'm sorry that's
cynical but it just is well I agree I've
said that before I think it's the easier
route to take than than sometimes going
with a brand new concept and having less
of a chance of it actually taking off
which is a shame but it's in the end
it's down to the down to the dollar
isn't it it's down to the back so yeah
and and these shows are ridiculously
expensive to make yeah so you know it's
insignificant investment so yeah which
means that they're going to be less
they're going to be less confident
because they're investing more in a
potential flop
yeah and and and they know they're like
like Lord of the Rings they knew they
were guaranteed a core audience they
knew it and even if the show wasn't very
good which you can argue about
um it's they knew they were getting a
core audience when they get a Stargate
reboot and the other thing is as well is
generate an interest
so the arc TV show gets
um green lip to be made nobody barely
notices they start talking about makers
of Stargate makers because that's how it
starts to get yeah prick up there is
um when Stargate gets greenlit which I'm
confident it will
um people are going to go crazy people
will pick take notice and that's think
it's it's free easy advertising which is
why
reboot sequels remakes are easy yeah and
that is
sad truth really but in another way
it's understandable you can't understand
though to a degree why they would go
live they're not fans they're they're
business people they want to make they
want to make profit they want to make a
lucrative uh new franchise with new idea
um and the best way to do it is to
reboot an old franchise or idea and I
think if we keep watching it they'll
keep making it yeah pretty much they're
going to reboot Superman again
I'm sorry Christopher Reeve is my only
Superman I'm not bothered all the other
Supermans well they just rebooted Batman
for the uh length time what about Batman
vs Superman film and I thought it was
shites about 10 years ago I couldn't
really enjoyed Batman versus Superman
colleague on the podcast he loved it I
just couldn't do it I actually I went
with my family and my son was only about
10 at the time and he looked at
something that was rubbish
again you know sometimes oh yeah that's
the way the world if we liked all
between things don't watch Justice
League then please okay okay if you say
don't then I won't I I came out of it
and I genuinely spent two hours just
punching myself in the dick
from what I was watching just sort of
like look up at the screens like
I hope you didn't post a review
somewhere but it might be an interesting
review on the Internet or something it
would have just me sat there going oh
yeah
it's awful
um
and honestly it's it's nonsensical at
times it makes okay
um but yeah it's and it killed the DC
and it should have done but but anyway
Mike from solar one there is a link in
the description to your channel thank
you thank you very much thank you for
having me on board it's been really nice
again at some point because I think we I
could talk and talk and talk about all
this stuff as you could probably tell so
maybe you want somebody to be part of uh
the crowd of people talk about whatever
then please give us a shout and I'll be
happy to be on board Mike you are
welcome it's literally anytime and um
and vice versa if ever you got a topic I
can be bothered to talk about I'll keep
you in mind thanks very much but uh but
honestly thank you very much um guys as
always everybody in the comments you've
been Sensational thank you so so much I
have to um kill time here for a second
because I have to find the end screen
button uh-oh okay um so and I will just
do I'm just going to run a quick advert
for you just one second
nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com
thank you very much Matty
Mike thank you again thank you very much
all the best good night good night
everybody bye
[Music]
thank you